what is german i am german i
feel german through and through and i was
born and raised here in berlin
and that my homeland of
course i have the feeling that i
belong to germany because i don't know anything
else germany is my
home
i describe myself as a german turk
because society kept telling me
hey you're not German
[music]
I can do whatever I want I can
change my name can dye my hair
and yet
people here will never see me as 100 percent
German just because of my
jewish origin where he has
explained umpteen times that i am actually not
german among german i
am not a natural part of
this society but i knew
that somehow i have to work out i have to
prove
in what i do and how i
behave that i am particularly german
is these little things this
degradation that you experience every day
as a small child you are
firmly convinced that you are german and that’s why you
come from
germany at school you
keep asking yourself this question where do you come
from where do you really come from you
quickly get into such an identity crisis that
you make decisions like that  must what is one
then now it's about getting people who
look like me out of
society
[music
] to be perceived as another person in this society
means
at the same time to experience violence
or means to
experience exclusion
i was seven years old  and was
invited to play on the play day
at least i said i was there
thought so now there is food and then
the mother said son such a
bastard like you not
always back where you
came from but you get out of the
bush quicker  I've also been to
the swimming pool where I've been told three
times that it's special  It's not
common for people like me to
swim against the street here
and a man came towards
me and he spat in my face and
he then said [ __ ] muslim the
saleswoman refused to speak to me
and but of course in the background you can
hear me  she talks about me with her colleague in
german and i
said clearly i speak through i
understand you the
color of your skin and the supposed race or ethnicity
makes a
difference how you are judged
[music]
homophobia hatred of jews being a housewife i
don't have an academic degree
I've also had situations where
people have asked
me I mean at my age yes that she's
still out do you think it's great
at eight o'clock that she wouldn't be
married oh you drink
alcohol that's of course a struggle
having to prove to people all the time
i'm not a fundamentalist and i'm
like that you had your nose operated on the
other one  n dead people are still
so close here who speaks German yes I
speak better German than you that
one is always perceived as a Turkey expert then
something
happens in Turkey what do you say about
that what do I know so I live
here too  to samoa there president well what
is he actually doing there in your country
in your home and where keeps
thinking no well my home is
actually germany
[music]
this question what is all this still remains to me
up to now no one
should really explain in any way one should  will come
on time is german because they are
very good ones that are said
to be germans weight i know a lot
who are not so i don't know
all of them who eat pork but there
is no typical german look
if you can't look at people if
they are german or not  you don't see
that so i dream german i think
german german is the language in which
i express myself best k  ann
and i would say that makes
me quite german being part of
society is for me being german
what in these three german
economy we all agree my father
taught me to be thrifty, to be
punctual and to treat others with respect
it  is now with kurdish culture i
'm definitely only german if i
'm successful if i have a
problem if i maybe fail at
something then i'm just the
channel i.e. someone who called me not german because of
my name or whatever
simply taz it is
not understood in my opinion germany
we are also a country of integration
[applause]
[music]
is the perception of racist
and anti-semitic voices
have become louder in recent years than they
used to be
i also see a connection with
the arrival of the first  in the federal parliament
the fear of the people that germany
will soon be ni  not be more Germany
but when I deal with the ideas of
these people
the first thing I ask myself is
define what you perceive as German
and tell me that I am not or
that I am destroying what you first
define German with mine  being there
with my series of existence
i'm really destroying it maybe you want to
be this german whatever it is
just get stuck here maybe even if
you don't even realize that
it is the case that we are so diverse
there are good migrants and there are
bad migrants they somehow
have dark hair and maybe they
are muslims they are not like the people we
actually want in germany
and the good foreigners are
western foreigners the eu citizens they
are suddenly not foreigners
but expats why is french
sexy and spanish  were all learning because
it's totally great and if it turns out
differently or Arabic  if
you're afraid of it you're not afraid of the spanish or french white christians why do
you have to live in fear and why do you have to make
me feel like i don't matter
just because i'm not the same
or think along those lines or something
looks like you i do
n't understand people who are afraid of
social change diversity tends to
produce positive things when
people
dream of a homogeneous society and talk about the fact that
they would like to have a homogeneous
society again then i think people tend
to overlook that the only reason
why it  maybe a reasonably
still the same society that was the reason
that those who didn't fit this concept
were deported and
murdered
[music]
less afraid of strangers more
living together more understanding each other
that's i think important for the
future that's not always us and you
must be but one that gives us the
whole society  I should just
do and change things instead of
always pointing out how
different people are
because it doesn't help anyone what that brings
don't tell us
germany is ready to change an immigration society
that's
not in the distant future that
's the reality  As I said, the
multicultural, multi-ethnic,
multi-religious society of today
has long been a
reality, but it also has to be recognized,
what I always find important is
that good role models are created, that
people with a migration
background or professionals are put at the
top of the executive board, I think we have to do
that  simply rethink being
German as long as being German is linked to the fact
that you shouldn’t have this strange other
then we won’t get any
further that it’s
not a question of blood or
the procedure right now but a
nationality or one’s own
internet Germany  d is open
multicultural many people live
very very peacefully with each other and the
people who deny other people that they are
German or that they
feel at home here because they don't
correspond to the image they
have of a German person these
people don't really
[music  ]